دخل الحوت الأبيض، الذي يعتقد البعض أنه تم
استخدامه كجاسوس لروسيا، إلى
منطقة جديدة وهو الآن في المياه السويدية
حيث يتتبع المتطوعون
تحركاته للمساعدة في الحفاظ على سلامته.
ميليسا بيل من CNN لديها قصة
تم رصد الجاسوس الروسي المزعوم لأول مرة
قبالة مياه السويد.  النرويج في عام 2019،
يبدو أن الحوت الأبيض يبحث عن
اهتمام الإنسان، وسرعان ما تلقى لقب "
فلاديمير" (تورية على
الحوت النرويجي وأصله الروسي المزعوم)، حيث
وجد أن الحوت كان يرتدي حزامًا
مزودًا بحوامل للكاميرا التي تحمل علامة تجارية،
ويعتقد الخبراء في سانت بطرسبرغ ذلك  ربما تم تدريبه من قبل
الجيش الروسي، وهو ما تنفي موسكو أن
الدلافين استخدمتها البحرية الروسية والأمريكية منذ فترة طويلة في
الدوريات
والكشف عن المتفجرات بجانب البشر
منذ وصوله إلى النرويج. وقد
تم تعقب رالدمير من قبل المتطوعين الذين يريدون
حمايته،
ونخشى أنه إذا فعل ذلك
قد
يضطرون إلى التفكير في خيار
القتل الرحيم له كما رأينا مع
الاستشهادات الأخرى في النرويج، ولكن
هذا لا يعني بأي حال من الأحوال أننا نعتقد أن
مزارعي السلمون ليس لديهم أي شيء سوى
حسن النية تجاه فالدامير وفلاديمير.  لقد كان
يأسر قلوب الإسكندنافية -
الحوت الذي يبدو معتادًا على
البشر أكثر من نوعه، وهو الآن
أبعد بكثير جنوبًا مما ينبغي أن يكون بعيدًا عن
العودة إلى مياه القطب الشمالي حيث
ربما وجد بعضًا من نوعه الذي
يتجه جنوبًا على طول الطريق إليه
ساحل السويد وفقًا لمنظمة
حوت واحدة غير حكومية، حيث تكون المياه دافئة للغاية
ومكتظة بالسكان بحيث لا يمكن للحوت الذي ربما تم
استخدامه للتجسس ولكن يتم مراقبته الآن بعناية فائقة في
باريس